ukrainian soldiers fired at a drone and
helped hundreds of civilians escape as
russia directly attacked an evacuation
route near a battered bridge northwest
of kiev on sunday
a shell exploded an ear
pin the mayor said at least eight
civilians were killed
over the weekend russia and ukraine
twice attempted to open humanitarian
corridors for fleeing civilians but they
weren't implemented
ukrainian authorities released footage
showing a long line of civilians waiting
to be evacuated from mariopol after
keefe said russian shelling disrupted
plans to evacuate 200 000 people
but the russian foreign minister said
local officials were refusing to provide
an opportunity for people to leave
through the corridors
more than 1.5 million civilians left
ukraine since russia invaded in what the
united nations called the fastest
growing refugee crisis in europe since
world war
ii in hassan the only regional capital
russia captured so far
gunshots rang out as people protested
against the occupation
ukraine's defense forces released
footage showing large crowds gathered in
the central square
the news agency storyful said it
corroborated and verified these videos
which show a man climbing on top of a
russian military vehicle and waving a
ukrainian flag
negotiators from russia and ukraine are
scheduled to meet for a third round of
ceasefire talks on monday the chances
for a breakthrough are slim as moscow
shows no sign of slowing down its
invasion